billy bush's battle with NBC in the
Today Show just got uglier because Billy
is lawyered up Billy Bush is on the
attack he's hired Hollywood lawyer
Marshall Grossman to help negotiate his
Today Show exit with NBC NBC had wanted
to get this over with by the end of the
week but clearly that's not going to
happen this negotiation has been a lot
more complicated than they'd hoped Billy
Bush does not want to go without a fight
Grossman's represented Clint Eastwood in
Steven Spielberg and earlier this year
he helped Erin Andrews win a 55 million
dollar judgment in her peephole cakes
Aaron is going to go after them and
we're gonna go after them with full
power
Grossman wouldn't comment on Bush's
negotiations but he did give us a
statement that clues us into their legal
strategy remember that leaked video of
Bush and Trump making lewd comments was
shot in 2005 at the time Bush was an NBC
Universal employee and Trump was the
star of a hit show on the network The
Apprentice
Grossman contends and we're quoting if
Billy had been passive or responded shut
the blank up to Trump Billy would have
been out of a job the next day it is
true that when you're interviewing a
celebrity you try to ingratiate yourself
with that person you try to make them
feel comfortable because you're about to
ask them a lot of questions that does
not excuse the kind of language and
behavior we heard on the NBC tape
Bush makes about three million dollars a
year yesterday he turned 45 NBC
colleagues were planning a surprise
party for Billy Bush he was going to
celebrate his birthday with them on
Saturday but that party's been canceled
for the fourth day in a row Carson Daly
filled in for Bush phones are ringing at
NBC with lots of TV agents recommending
lots of different possible hosts for the
9:00 a.m. hour Carson Daly and willie
Geist are too obvious in-house
candidates